[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and the
day we've been waiting for is finally
here the samsung galaxy s8 and s8 plus
are officially revealed now i say that a
little bit ironically obviously because
this phone was leaked everywhere but
it's okay it's good to actually like see
it in person now and feel it in the hand
so now that everything is officially
official this is everything you need to
know about this new phone first of all
from the very beginning it was all about
that display the design the lack of
bezels just the jaw dropping edge to
edge nature of that front panel that's
where samsung went all in with this
phone so the galaxy s8 is rocking a 5.8
inch 2960x1440
oled display and the s8 plus is rocking
a 6.2 inch oled with the same resolution
so that's extremely sharp and that's an
18 and a half by 9 aspect ratio for
those counting so it's a little bit
taller even than the 2x1 aspect ratio
from the lg g6 so these are huge
displays and very tall resolutions but
of course the footprint of these phones
when you compare them to something with
a more traditional larger bezel
it's awesome it fits in the footprint of
a phone with a way smaller screen
they're calling it the infinity display
i'm calling it like the almost
bezel-less look you can call it whatever
you want i really like it now it's not a
completely new concept the galaxy s7
edge had the display glass melting over
the edges already last year but for some
reason that phone's edges always felt
like kind of sharp to me never really
got quite comfortable with it but the s8
edges here feel much softer they're much
more seamless feeling than before which
no doubt took a lot of careful
engineering and then of course they push
the display further up to the top and
further towards the bottom of the phone
by getting rid of the physical buttons
and replacing them with software buttons
so okay finally samsung is actually now
switching from hardware buttons on the
bottoms and the chins of all their
phones to the software on-screen buttons
that's great i love them but what does
that mean we lose by switching well
first of all samsung's software buttons
are not pretty i mean maybe it's just me
but i think they're pretty ugly uh and
they're also out of order like the back
button should still be on the left but
luckily we can reorder these buttons in
the software to switch the order if we
want we can't change the way they look
but there's that and you also lose a
physical home button which had the
fingerprint reader on it on the last
phone so the fingerprint reader now here
moves up to the back of the phone and
way up by the camera this one
is kind of a stretch and i actually
don't mind you know fingerprint readers
on the backs of phones like on the pixel
xl for example when i'm holding my phone
in a normal reading position the
fingerprint reader is actually easily
reachable so i don't mind that it's in
the middle of the back but these
stretched out samsung phones are a
little bit taller so even with my big
hands holding the s8 in a normal
position puts the fingerprint reader
just a little bit out of reach so i have
to stretch a bit to find it and then
with the s8 plus again when it's way up
at the top of the phone like this if i
just hold it normally and i turn the
phone over it's like completely out of
place and if i try to find it blind
there's not really a big indentation to
know exactly where it is so that's
definitely something that's going to
take some getting used to many people i
think will need to use two hands with
this in fact in the official samsung
commercial the dude does it with two
hands so that fingerprint reader
placement is a little odd but i think
everything else about this hardware
samsung pretty much hit it out the park
this finally feels like a 2017 or even
2020 futuristic smartphone design in the
seamless beautiful type of way that we
dream of but without sacrificing really
any functionality or features it's still
thin and pretty lightweight phone it
still has usb type c at the bottom with
fast charging it still has a headphone
jack it's still fully ip68 water
resistant still has wireless charging
still has a micro sd card slot for
expandable storage and with all that
sandwiched between the sheets of metal
and glass the galaxy s8 will also have
pretty much some of the best specs you
can find in any android phone so
snapdragon 835
four gigs of ram first phone in the
world with bluetooth 5.0 and it brings
iris scanner also back from the dead
from that galaxy note 7. my only
question mark here is the battery the
only difference between the s8 and the
s8 plus there's not any features it's
just the physical size so the displays
are different and the battery sizes are
different it's three thousand milliamp
hours on the galaxy s8 and 3500 milliamp
hours on the s8 plus and a 3000mah
battery can seem decent maybe a little
bit small but the number one draw of
battery on a phone is the display and
it's so easy to forget while holding
that this is a 5.8 inch display it's
huge so a 3 000 milliamp hour battery on
a 5.8 inch display
not really too sure if that's going to
hold up and then same thing with the
bigger one the s8 plus is a 3 500
milliamp hour battery which seems pretty
decent size but it's a 6.2 inch display
not a lot of 6.2 inch display phones out
there and it's also a super high res
super bright display i mean that's going
to be a big draw that's definitely
something we're going to be testing for
the full review now the cameras on the
back of this phone as far as i can tell
are the same as the galaxy s7 from last
year so 12 megapixel camera f 1.7
aperture optical image stabilization the
whole deal it's high-end and that's not
a bad thing at all that was a really
good camera but obviously that's not
exactly pushing the limits here it's
just a pretty safe bet that will do you
just fine and then of course there's the
software a lot of people have mixed
feelings about this stuff including me
obviously i like stock android and this
is not that this is samsung's ux on top
of android 7.0 with all their slightly
redesigned colorful icons and launcher
and everything here
it feels fine with the hardware they
have a new set of wallpapers to look
pretty great on this display and the
home screen icons and widgets are a
little tweaked but overall it's nothing
drastically different from before there
are some neat tricks up at sleeve like
there's this button that shows up when
you're watching youtube videos full
screen that basically lets you do what
the ipad does and punch in a little bit
to fill the display if you really hate
the black bars on the side your call
obviously you can still rearrange the
software buttons at the bottom like i
said i'm sure we'll find even more stuff
when we get to playing with this phone
even more but the biggest new software
feature of the galaxy s8 is actually its
personal assistant called bixby
and to me it's a little bit confusing
just the way it exists on the phone at
least to users i think so bixby does all
the same things that google assistant
does
but by samsung instead of by google so
you can it'll show you a bunch of cards
in an order that's relevant to you so it
tries to show you information that it
thinks is important before you need it
it's really similar to google now and
what google does with the cards you can
access it by swiping over from your home
screen just like google and bixby even
has its own freaking button on the side
of the phone look power button on one
side then volume rocker and bixby button
on the other side that's a big
commitment now to be fair there were a
bunch of other like image recognition
and context recognition things uh that
they claimed bixby could do but they
couldn't show us any of these things
that's going to be launching with the
phone but the funny thing is this is
still an android phone it's still
android 7.0 which means it still also
has google assistant on the phone if you
long press the home button sure enough
you get google assistant popping right
up so it's weird i got this s voice
rebooted type of vibe with those two
things doing the same thing existing
next to each on their own the phone it's
kind of a weird thing obviously we all
know how s voice went down and i really
hope that this isn't as bad as s voice
we'll give it the benefit of the doubt
we'll see when it launches but until
then that's just kind of a cross your
fingers and hope type of thing so
overall as a package the galaxy s8 is
pretty impressive promising i might even
say to me it looks like samsung really
picked their battles with this one there
are certain areas where they they
clearly really wanted to go all out and
push the boundaries the design
the display and it shows and it's that's
on the outside of the phone but other
areas where they're definitely not
pushing forward too hard are also pretty
obvious the camera the battery but as an
entire phone i'm pretty optimistic for
the galaxy s8 so there you have it
that's everything that you need to know
with this new flagship it's coming out
on april 21st that's when you can be
able to get it
feel free to share this video with
anyone who you think might be interested
in this bomb new flagship well actually
probably hopefully not bomb it i mean it
might be the bomb but like not the bomb
in that way you know what i mean i think
you know what i mean thanks for watching
expect a full review of this phone
obviously talk to you guys in the next
one
peace
[Music]